GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I AM BRET BAIER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GOING
HEAVY-METAL TONIGHT, IMPOSING
TOUGH NEW TARIFFS ON IMPORTED
STEEL AND ALUMINUM.
IT'S A MOVE HE SAYS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT VITAL AMERICAN
INDUSTRIES.
CRITICS SAY IT WILL BACKFIRE,
WHO HURT U.S. CONSUMERS AND
POSSIBLY IGNITE A TRADE WAR.
JOHN ROBERTS STARTS US OFF
TONIGHT WITH ANOTHER
PRESIDENTIAL MOVE VERY FEW
PEOPLE SAW COMING.
>> THE TIMING OF ALL THIS, THE
ANNOUNCEMENT TOOK EVERYONE BY
SURPRISE.
THE WHITE HOUSE HASN'T FIGURED
OUT HOW THIS IS GOING TO WORK
BUT THE PRESIDENT WAS EAGER TO
GET THE WORD OUT.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
EVERYONE.
>> WASN'T ON HIS PUBLIC SCHEDULE
TODAY, AND THE WHITE HOUSE
INSISTED AN ANNOUNCEMENT WASN'T
COMING UNTIL NEXT WEEK.
TODAY PRESIDENT TRUMP UNVEILED
PUNITIVE SANCTIONS ON FOREIGN
ALUMINUM AND STEEL.
>> 25% FOR STEEL.
10% FOR ALUMINUM.
IT WILL BE FOR A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME.
>> THE AD LIB ANNOUNCEMENT
BLINDSIDED WHITE HOUSE STAFF.
THE PRESS SECRETARY INSISTED IT
SHOULDN'T BE A SURPRISE.
THE PRESIDENT TALKED AT LENGTH
DURING THE CAMPAIGN ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF FOREIGN METALS BEING
DUMPED INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THE STOCK MARKET TANKED ON THE
NEWS.
AT ONE POINT DOWN MORE THAN 500
POINTS.
FORMER U.S. TRADE REPRESENTATIVE
SENATOR ROB PORTMAN CONCERNED
THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED TARIFFS
BEFORE ANY OF THE DETAILS WERE
FINALIZED.
>> IT DEPENDS WHAT COUNTRIES
MIGHT BE EXEMPTED, WHICH
PRODUCTS MIGHT BE EXEMPTED.
WE DON'T KNOW THE DETAILS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT'S GOING TO
COME OUT NEXT WEEKEND PRESIDENT
AT HIS COMMENTS TODAY.
>> PORTMAN AGREES THAT TARIFFS
ARE NEEDED TO PROTECT STEEL
COMPANIES AND PRODUCTS ESSENTIAL
TO NATIONAL SECURITY.
REPUBLICAN SENATOR PAT TOOMEY OF
PENNSYLVANIA SAID WE SHOULD USE
EXISTING LAWS TO COMBAT DUMPING.
IN A STATEMENT SAYING "CHANGING
COURSE FROM THIS APPROACH BY
INVOKING NATIONAL SECURITY AS A
MEANS OF IMPOSING NEW TARIFFS ON
ALL KINDS OF IMPORTED STEEL IS A
BIG MISTAKE THAT WILL INCREASE
COSTS ON AMERICAN CONSUMERS,
COST OUR COUNTRY JOBS, AND
INVITE RETALIATION FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES."
THE ACTION IS PREDOMINANTLY
AIMED AT CHINA WITCHES DUMPING
CHEAP STEEL PRODUCTS INTO THE
U.S.
>> YOU LIKE THE TARIFFS WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
YOU LIKE THE TARIFFS WHERE THEY
WON'T BE DUMPING ON OUR COUNTRY.
WHAT THEY DO IS THEY DON'T
MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF PRODUCT IN
OUR COUNTRY.
IT KILLS, DESTROYS OUR COMPANIES
AND JOBS.
>> THE MOVE MAY AFFECT AMERICA'S
CLOSEST ALLIES.
CANADA DECLARED ANY TARIFF
AGAINST IT STEEL WOULD BE
UNACCEPTABLE.
BRITAIN SAID WE ARE PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED BY ANY MEASURES THAT
WOULD IMPACT THE U.K. STEEL AND
ALUMINUM INDUSTRIES.
ONE GROUP THAT DEFINITELY LIKES
THE PLAN, THE STEEL AND ALUMINUM
COMPANY CHIEFS WHO MET WITH THE
>> WE ARE CONVINCED WE WILL SEE
VERY QUICK ACTION, DEFINITIVE
ACTION, AND ACTION THAT IS
MEANINGFUL AND LONG-LASTING.
>> A DAY AFTER THE WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR HOPE
HICKS ANNOUNCED SHE WOULD SOON
BE LEAVING THE WHITE HOUSE,
SHOOTING DOWN REPORTS THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
H.R. McMASTER WAS ON HIS WAY
OUT THE DOOR.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYING THERE ARE